tawny crazy ants get the label crazy
because they appear to run in chaotic
curlicues but the insects also have
another bit of crazy they can do battle
with some much bigger ants like fire
ants and win in the southern United
States invasive fire ants wipe out
native ant species disrupt ecosystems
move into people's yards and sting
anything within reach but crazy ants are
pushing fire ants out of their territory
and taking their nests now scientists
say they have discovered one of the
crazy ants tricks to surviving fire ants
venom fire ants release drops of a
potent venom from their hind ends after
touching a droplet of venom the crazy
ant curls its hind end up between its
legs and gives itself a vigorous rubdown
tests showed that the crazy ants were
grooming themselves with formic acid to
detoxify the fire ant venom treating
ants of another species with formic acid
saved their lives after being exposed to
fire in venom the researchers report the
results appear February 13th and science
still even though crazy ants don't sting
they can build up in huge numbers
rushing around houses and moving into
electrical devices in their crazy way so
people may not like them any more than
fire ants